good morning john first um your video
made everyone i know laugh very hard
so good job on that in the last few
weeks i've seen a lot of conversation
i think because of the release of the
book code breaker about jennifer doudna
who's one of the
pioneers of crispr gene editing about
whether
and how and should we edit the genomes
of people and also
of people who don't even exist yet
usually the conversations go something
like this like should we edit people
so they don't have diseases yes and then
as we continue down the path as it's
getting hairier it's like what about
height should we
allow people to edit their children to
be taller so they can be better at
sports but then at some point you get to
intelligence and often times the defense
is like well we all benefit
if there are more super smart people to
solve hard problems
that sentence doesn't make sense and i
want to talk about why it is not
that intelligence isn't to some extent
genetic like studies show that it is
i just don't think that we have wrapped
our brains around what the heck it is we
mean
when we say intelligent i'm not even
sure if i have blonde hair
we're arguing about whether a hot dog is
a sandwich do you think we can figure
out what intelligence is but here's the
thing we know two identical twins
are more likely to have more similar
scores on intelligence tests than two
fraternal twins so we're talking about
two people who shared the exact same
environment they were born at the same
time raised by the same parents
they were in the same womb and the ones
that are genetically the same
have closer together intelligence scores
than the ones that are fraternal or
less similar but environment versus
genetics is a really hairy thing that's
kind of hard to
continue to wrap your minds around so an
example let us imagine
a precocious overconfident young man who
has adhd and sensory processing issues
and will never in his life read faster
than an 8th grade level and let's assume
that all that stuff is 100 genetic if
that child is born at the right moment
and with the right support
all those things might influence each
other in a way that will result
in the acquisition of intelligence and
if identical twins
shared those traits grew up in the same
house had all that same support it would
test
similarly on the same test but if any
one of those traits was a little bit
different and i'm talking like five
traits here when really there's
hundreds or if their environment was
different if they had less support if
people indulged in their overconfidence
a little less those same traits instead
of helping a student
might hinder us too the potential was
genetic though complicated and
reinforced by lots of different factors
the ability to capture the potential
was environmental but here's what i
think is the most important thing here
environment
isn't just across an individual society
and it's not just across various
cultures
it's also across time we don't know
right now
what traits are going to be useful to
the people of the future
because their world is going to be
different from ours i would have had a
very different path in life
if it were not for computers i have a
sensory processing disorder i have adhd
i do not read as fast as the average
ninth grader but with a combination of
luck it being born at a time when the
right tools existed and
support what might have been liabilities
at another time in another place
turned into assets intelligence really
is more about what we
need right now from people than it is
about any particular
innate thing i think of it as being well
suited to the world in which you happen
to have been born into not
as some people seem to imagine some kind
of on off switch that's like genius not
genius
genius not genius as a species we do not
yet understand
the genetics of eye color the idea that
we could genetically modify a child
to be more intelligent isn't just wild
hubris it is also i think a dangerous
misunderstanding of what intelligence is
if we design people to be good at living
in the world as it is now
we do two things first we deny the
reality the world needs
lots of different people with lots of
different kinds of abilities but worse
if we're designing people to be good at
living in the world as it exists at one
moment
we are depriving ourselves of the
diversity that will allow us
to have people that will be good at
living in the world as it will exist in
the future and that is not just a lesson
we need to learn
before genetically engineering new
humans it's a lesson we need to learn
for educating enabling and appreciating
humans
now john i'll see you on tuesday